with pre-existing conditions which will
increase
now including those with lung scarring
and heart damage as a consequence of
covert 19. it provides coverage
for more than 20 million americans
who get the care they need if they're
showing symptoms
of covert 19. the law that fulfills our
moral obligation
here in america health care is a right
for all
not a privilege for a few
but as all of you know i know that out
of our collective pain
we're going to find a collective purpose
to control the pandemic
to save lives and to heal as a nation
today i'm pleased to announce a team
that was going to do just that
is a team of world-class experts at the
top of their fields
crisis tested defined by a deep sense of
duty
honor and patriotism already
ready to jump in they've been advising
me many of them for a long time
and they're going to be ready on day one
to spare not a single effort
to get this pandemic under control so we
get back to work
get back to our lives get back to our
loved ones
they'll lead the kova 19 response across
the government to accelerate testing
fix our supply chain and distribute the
vaccine
the work of my economic team because
controlling the pandemic
delivering better health care and
reviving the economy
go hand in hand but work with my foreign
policy and national security teams
because we can only beat the virus here
at home it must be beaten everywhere
or it comes back to haunt us again today
i'm announcing
that in consultation with dr tony fauci
we developed the first three objectives
of the new initiative
that i'm asking this team to complete
once i'm sworn in our first 100 days in
office
my first hundred days won't end the
covet 19 virus
i can't promise that but
but we did not get into this mess
quickly
we're not going to get out of it quickly
it's going to take some time
but i'm absolutely convinced that in 100
days we can change the course of the
disease
and change life in america for the
better
first my first 100 days
is going to require i'm going to ask for
a masking plan
every one for the first hundred days of
my administration to wear a mask
it will start with my sign in order on
day one to require
masks where i can under the law
like federal buildings interstate travel
on planes
trains and buses i'll also be working
with the governors and mayors
to do the same in their states and their
cities
we're going to require mass wherever
possible
but this goes beyond government action
and so as a new president i'm going to
speak directly to the american people
and say what i'm saying now we need your
help
wear a mask for just 100 days
it's the easiest thing you can do to
reduce covet cases hospitalizations and
death
help yourself your family and your
community
whatever your politics or point of view
mask up for 100 days once we take office
100 days to make a difference it's not a
political statement it's a patriotic act
it won't be the end of our efforts but
it's a necessary and easy beginning an
easy start secondly this team
this team will help get at the latest at
the last
100 million covet 19 vacci at least
100 million coveted vaccine shots into
the arms of the american people
in the first hundred days a hundred
million shots
in the first hundred days and will
follow the guidance of science to get
the vaccines of those
most at risk that includes health care
professionals
people in long-term care and as soon as
possible
it will include educators this will be
the most
efficient mass vaccination plan in u.s
history
i credit everyone who's gotten up to
we've has gotten us
up to this point but developing a
vaccine is only
one herculean task distributing it is
another herculean task
you know in vaccines in a vial
only work if they're injected into an
arm of people especially those most at
risk
this will be one of the hardest and most
costly operational
challenges in our nation's history we're
going to need congress
to fully fund vaccine distribution to
all corners of the country
to everyone i'm encouraged by the
bipartisan efforts in congress
around a 900 billion economic relief
package
which i've said is critical but this
package is only a start
for more action early next year we must
also focus
significant resources on direct public
health response to covert 19.
our preliminary view of trump
administration's vaccine distribution
plans confirms media reports
without urgent action by this congress
this month to put sufficient resources
into
vaccine distribution and manufacturing
which the bipartisan group was working
on there's a real chance
that after an early round of
vaccinations
the effort will slow and stall let me
repeat
we need congress to finish the
bipartisan work underway
now where millions of americans may wait
months longer to get the vaccine months
longer
than they otherwise would have to get
weight to get the vaccine
the vaccination look
and then we're going to need additional
action next year to fund the rest of the
distribution efforts
we'll also need the trump administration
to act now though
to purchase the doses that has
negotiated with pfizer and modernity
and to work swiftly to scale
manufacturing
to u.s populations and the world
this can be fixed if it does if it is
fixed my team will be able to get at
least 100 million vaccinations
done in my first 100 days
the third thing i'm going to ask in 100
days
it should be a national priority to get
our kids back into school
and keep them in school if congress
provides the funding we need to protect
students educators and staff
if states and cities put strong public
health measures in place
that we all follow then my team will
work to see
that a majority of our schools can be
open by the end of my first 100 days
that's right we'll look to have the most
schools open
that we can possibly in 100 days
if congress provides the funding we need
it's not a secret how to do it masking
vaccinations opening schools these are
the three key goals for my first
100 days but we'll still have much to do
in the year ahead and sadly much
difficulty as well
will be far far from done
yet it's possible after 100 days we'll
be much
further along in the fight against this
pandemic
and i'm grateful to the members of my
kova team
that i'd like to introduce to you now
who will lead the way
i'm really proud of this group for
secretary of health and education
service i nominated
javier baqueria you know
javier bashir excuse me
he currently the attorney general of
california leading the second largest
justice department in america
only behind the united states department
of justice
and for nearly 25 years before that he
was a congressman
representing los angeles one of the
largest america's largest
and most diverse cities javier spent
a career fighting to expand access to
health care
reducing racial health disparities
protecting the affordable care act
and take on powerful special interests
to prey on
profit off of people's health from
opioid manufacturers
to big tobacco during this pandemic
he'll protect
the safety of the front-line healthcare
workers
rooted out the fraud
from the bad actors to take advantage of
people
and he stood up for homeowners trying to
pay their mortgages during this
devastating economic crisis
there are things he's already fought for
and accomplished in many cases
and his secretary hhs secretary he will
skillfully oversee
the cdc and the fda medicare and
medicaid
no matter what happens in the supreme
court he'll lead our efforts to build on
the affordable care act
to work to dramatically expand coverage
and take bold steps to lower health care
at prescription drug costs
javier is a key leader who lead
a key agency charged with protecting the
health and wellness of the american
people
he's also the first latino leading hhs
the son of a working family-class
working-class
immigrant family that came from mexico
a true public servant who's dedicated
his career
in the service of the people and the
service of this country
that we all love to serve as coordinator
of the kova 19 response team i'm turning
a world-class manager and leader
i've known jeff for a long time from the
first
and last days of the obama biden white
house and throughout the campaign and
now the transition
there's no one else you'd want to help
manage some of the most consequential
and complex priorities of a country
director of national economic council
for president obama
acting director for the office of
management budget
he's there was there during the great
recession as he went from crisis to
recovery to resurgence in eight years
he was there to lead the team and help
implement the affordable care act
and get healthcare.gov up and working
at a critical moment that was the
monumental feat that required vision
patience experience fortitude
and real expertise well-respected across
the aisle
and around the country from business to
labor leaders to entrepreneurs to
educators
chairman of the board the children's
national medical center one of the
world's top children's hospitals
jeff knows how to build and lead a team
how to identify and solve problems and
how to fully mobilize the federal
government on behalf of the health
safety and prosperity of the american
people
jeff zeins thank you for being willing
to do this again
the surgeon general of the united states
i nominate a man who could do any of
these jobs i think but dr vivek murthy
you've worked with me for a long time
he's a renowned physician and research
scientist
a trusted national leader on health care
and for me
a trusted advisor during the campaign
and transition
this will be the second time serving as
america's doctor having served in this
role under president obama
during his tenure he took on some of the
most
pressing public health issues we faced
excuse me from the opioid crisis to
threats to america's mental health
i've asked dr murphy to serve again
as surgeon general but with
expanded responsibilities he will be a
key public voice on the covet response
to restore public trust
and faith in science and medicine one of
the reasons doc i ask you to do this
when you speak people listen they trust
you you have a way of communicating
they can just see in your eyes i mean
sincerely
it's a really really important thing to
be communicated now
when people are in so much doubt it'll
also be a key advisor to me
and help lead all government approach to
broader public health issues
we've talked a lot about the need to
vastly increase the focus on mental
health in the country
addiction and substance use disorders
social and environmental detriments
to health and much more so i'm really
looking forward and thank you for doing
this above all
i believe i believe as well as any
person i've ever worked with
that can help restore faith in this
country
as a place of possibilities the son of
indian immigrants
who raise their children always believe
in the promise of america
dr murthy will be one of my most trusted
public health and medical advisors
and i'm grateful i mean sincerely i'm
grateful
for your willingness to continue to stay
in public service
and for director of the center for
disease control
cdc and prevention i might add
i appoint rochelle
wolinski she's a chief infectious
disease she's chief of infectious
disease
one of the country's most preeminent
hospitals
massachusetts general in boston a
distinguished professor
at harvard medical school and a
world-class physician
one of the nation's foremost experts on
testing
treatment and eradication of viruses
she has served on the on the front lines
on the covert crisis
she's conducted groundbreaking research
on vaccine delivery including
how to reach underserved communities
that are too often
hit first hardest and treat it last
dr olinsky's work was instrumental in
helping the world
mitigate the public health crisis of hiv
aids it inspired her as a young doctor
to pursue
her pioneering research in virus
containment
now she will bring her expertise to bear
against covet 19.
she's uniquely qualified to restore
morale and public trust she'll marshal
our finest scientists and public health
experts at cdc
to turn the tide on this urgent crisis
we're facing today
because of the pandemic's
disproportionate impact on communities
of color
i concluded that i wanted we needed
a kova 19 equity task force
to chair that to chair it i appoint
dr marcela nunez smith one of the
country's
foremost experts on health care
disparities
associate professor of medicine and
public health and management at yale
school of medicine
founding director of yale's equity
research and innovation center
and co-chair of mykova 19 transition
advisory board
dr nunez smith will lead our efforts to
provide care
to the communities most in need and most
affected by the pandemic and often
overlooked
she'll ensure that fairness and equity
are at the center of
every part of our response
this is a central front in our fight
against this pandemic
and i'm grateful dr nunez smith will
lead this
charge and finally
as both head of my national institute of
allergy and infectious disease
and my chief medical advisor on covert
19 i'm pleased
to say that dr tony fauci will be
a member of my covet team by now
tony in need dr fauci needs no
introduction
but he'll have my gratitude when i'm
president the seventh president
he will have served we know each other
we've known each other for a long time
and i'm so grateful when i called him
almost before i asked he said yes
i've seen him take on hiv aids h1n1
ebola
zika cova 19 and every infection's
infectious disease in between over his
nearly 40 years of service to our
country
dr fauci's trusted a truth-teller
a patriot like every good doctor
he'll tell me what i need to know not
what i
want to know what i need to know not
what i want to know
this is my core covet health care team
before january 20th we'll be adding more
leaders to oversee vaccine distribution
the supply chain testing and other key
functions
to each of you on this team you have my
gratitude
and i mean that you're my gratitude for
answering the call to serve
and to your families i know many of you
are making real sacrifices to do this
thank you and to your families i say
thank you directly
we couldn't do this without them
or without you the families supporting
this
and to the american people i know we've
all had a lot of sleepless nights this
year
so many of you staring at the ceiling
tonight worrying my god what happens
what happens it strikes my family what
happens if i lose my insurance
what happens am i going to be okay is my
family going to be okay
all i can tell you is the truth we're in
a very dark winter
things may well get worse before they
get better
a vaccine may soon be available we need
to level
with one another it'll take longer than
we would like to distribute it to all
corners of the country
depending on how it gets started off
between now and the time i'm sworn in
we'll need to persuade enough americans
to take the vaccine
many of them have become very cynical
about its usefulness
it's daunting but i promise you
that we'll make progress starting on day
one
we didn't get into this mess quickly
it's going to take time to fix
but we can do this that's the truth
and telling you the truth is what this
team
vice president-elect harris and i will
always do give it to you straight from
the shoulder
as roosevelt used to say this is the
toughest challenge america has ever
faced
one of the toughest but we know that we
can overcome
and heal together as one nation
to all of you on the front lines the
healthcare professionals
first responders grocery store workers
delivery truck drivers
educators parents our children i say
thank you
we can do this we can do this
i want to thank you for everything
you've done to get us through this
crisis so far
and we're never going to give up on you
i promise you and we'll never give up on
our country
we can do this there's nothing we've
ever failed to do we've decided to do
together
together that's america
all those who have lost in this pandemic
all those who are sick and suffering
our hearts go out to you many of us know
what it's like
may god bless you all and may god
protect our troops
thank you for listening now i'd like to
turn it over to the team
starting with our next secretary of
health and human service
javier sarah
javier thank you for being willing to
take on the responsibility
along with carolina my wife and natalia
olivia clarissa and yvonne greetings
from california
mr president-elect madam vice
president-elect
i am honored and excited to join your
team
the mission of the department of health
and human services has never been as
vital or as urgent
as it is today the covet pandemic and
its economic fallout have thrust
families into crisis
too many americans are sick or have lost
loved ones
too many have lost their jobs and with
that their health care
and hope you have made it clear mr
president-elect
that to build back a prosperous america
we need a
healthy america that then will be job
one
for your team at hhs
55 years ago during another time of
hardship former health secretary
and fellow californian john gardner said
what we have before us are some
breathtaking opportunities
disguised as insoluble problems
gardner went on to help president lyndon
johnson build the great society
ushering in medicare medicaid and civil
rights
that brought greater equity greater
opportunity and greater hope
to all americans now it's our turn
to discover the breathtaking
opportunities before us in the midst of
this hardship and pain
it's our turn to build up and to back up
our doctors and medical professionals
our hospitals and clinics
battling the coronavirus our turn to
restore faith
and confidence in our leaders to deliver
solutions
that unite and heal us and inoculate us
from fear
our turn to spur our brightest minds to
launch the next generation of innovative
medicines and cures
and it is our turn to build a nation
where
as the president-elect so often says
health care is a right
not a privilege at hhs tackling
pandemics
saving lives keeping us healthy should
be our calling card
and we won't forget that there is a
second h in hhs
the human services the work we do for
our children
seniors and disabled they will stand
tall
in a biden-harris hhs
almost a year ago on new year's day my
father manuel
passed away peacefully at home
surrounded by his family
we got to celebrate christmas together
and when the end came
my dad knew we were there with him
no one no one should ever have to die
alone
in a hospital bed loved ones forced to
stay away
that seems so contrary to the values of
a great nation
the values that drew my parents like
generations before and after them to
come to america
manuel and maria teresa had only their
health
and hope when they arrived in california
a road construction worker with a sixth
grade education
and a clerical worker who arrived in her
teens from guadalajara
jalisco mexico as they helped build a
better california
they built a pretty good partnership
that lasted 67 years
and while they never got to experience
the inside of a college
they did send their four kids there as
well as to the military
now president-elect biden has offered me
a breathtaking opportunity
to work with his team to shape our
health care future
i share the president-elect and vice
president-elect's determination
to rebuild unity and civility in america
we know it takes hard work we know we
must do it together
we know it will be key to building
critical momentum and support
for the prevention and treatment of the
coronavirus
those values and priorities will help us
emerge from this pandemic
a stronger more just and more equitable
nation
literally there are millions of small
business owners and tens of millions of
workers
who are counting on us i am proud to
have this chance
to implement the president-elect's
vision for a better america
through the challenging assignments that
are in store for the department
of health and human services mr
president-elect
madam vice president-elect thank you for
this opportunity
to serve
mr president-elect madam vice
president-elect
thank you for your trust and your
confidence
i bring greetings and thanks also from
my grandmother sarojini
for my sister rashmi and brother-in-law
amit and from my dear wife alice
and my dear children deja sanchandi
we thank you for this opportunity to
serve
when i left my role as surgeon general i
never dreamed i would have the
opportunity to serve again
and in this moment of crisis when so
many americans
have fallen sick and lost loved ones
when people have lost their jobs and are
struggling for child
care i feel grateful to be able to do
everything i can to end this pandemic
while this is a daunting task
we absolutely have as a country
what we need to overcome this virus
we have world-class scientists
we have courageous medical professionals
who are risking their lives
to care for the ill we have companies
that are on the cusp of delivering
vaccines
and most of all we are blessed with
generous and compassionate people
all across america who are stepping up
to help those who are struggling
if we work together we will overcome
this pandemic
and return to our lives but covet 19 is
not the only health crisis we face
if anything it has underscored a host of
other epidemics
that are devastating families and
shortening lifespans
crises like addiction including the
opioid crisis
our aspiring mental health concerns
our glaring racial health disparities
and the high rates of chronic illness
that we face
like diabetes and heart disease
these challenges are both caused by but
also exacerbated by
broader societal issues from the
economic strains so many people are
facing
to the disconnection and loneliness that
many of us feel
in my new expanded role i will work to
bring a health
focus to our policies across government
so that our schools our workplaces and
our communities
can be forces for strengthening our
health and well-being
but the truth is that the very best
policies and even the best vaccines and
treatments
will not heal our nation unless we also
overcome the fear
anxiety anger and distrust
that so many americans are feeling right
now
so more than anything i will come to
this role
as a doctor one who learned the most
important lessons about medicine not in
medical school
but from the clinic that my parents
opened when they first came to america
as immigrants decades ago as a child
i saw how they took their time not just
to diagnose illnesses
but to ask their patients families about
their lives
to pour over pictures of children and
grandchildren that were pulled from
wallets
they listened deeply to people's stories
and their struggles
often running well over their
appointment time
and they taught me that the best doctor
is not an authority figure who writes
prescriptions
but rather a partner in healing someone
who sees
patients in their fullest humanity and
empowers them
to take charge of their health that is
the kind of doctor i have always tried
to be
and if confirmed that is the kind of
surgeon general
that i will strive to be i will dedicate
myself to caring for every american
driven always by science and facts
by head and by heart and endlessly
grateful to serve
one of the few countries in the world
where the grandson
of a poor farmer in india could be asked
by the president-elect
to look out for the health of an entire
nation
that is a testament to the promise of
america
one that i will seek to fulfill every
day as surgeon general
thank you so much and thank you again mr
president-elect
and madam vice president-elect for this
opportunity to serve
thank you
[Music]
mr president-elect madam vice
president-elect
i am honored by the trust you have
placed in me to serve the american
people during this critical time
i want to thank my amazing husband and
our three wonderful sons
for answering this call along with me
as all doctors and public servants know
these jobs ask a great deal not only of
us but of our families
the pandemic that brought me here today
is one that struck america
and the world more than 30 years ago
because my medical training
happened to coincide with some of the
most harrowing years of the hiv aids
crisis
as a medical student i saw firsthand how
the virus
ravaged bodies and communities
inside the hospital i witnessed people
lose strength
and hope while outside the hospital
i witnessed those same patients mostly
gay men
and members of vulnerable communities be
stigmatized and marginalized
by their nation and many of its leaders
a scientific breakthrough came in 1995
when the fda approved the first aids
cocktail
and we saw the first glimmers of hope
i've dedicated my career ever since to
researching
and treating infectious diseases and to
ending the hiv aids crisis
for good now a new virus is ravaging us
it's striking hardest once again at the
most vulnerable
the marginalized the underserved
nearly 15 million americans
have been infected over
280 million loved ones
are gone the pain is accelerating
our defenses have worn down we are
losing life
and hope at an alarming rate
i never anticipated i would take on a
role helping lead our national response
and government service was never part of
my plan
but every doctor knows that when a
patient is coding
your plans don't matter you answer the
code
and when the nation is coding if you are
called to serve you
serve you run to take care of people
to stop the bleeding to stabilize
to give them hope and a fighting chance
to come back
stronger that's what doctors do
i'm honored to work with an
administration that understands that
leading with science is the only way
to deliver breakthroughs to deliver hope
and to bring our nation back to full
strength
to the american people and to each and
every one of you
at the cdc i promise to work with you
to harness the power of american science
to fight this virus and prevent
unnecessary illness
and deaths so that we can all get
back to our lives mr president-elect
madam vice president-elect i thank you
for this opportunity
thank you
mr president-elect madam vice
president-elect
thank you so much for this opportunity
to serve the american people
i'm proud to go to work with leaders who
are deeply committed to science
and to centering equity in our response
to this pandemic
and not as a secondary concern not as a
box to check
but as a shared value woven into all of
the work that we do
and prioritized by every member of the
biden harris team
i'm enormously thankful to my research
team
and to my colleagues to president
salovey
and the other leadership here at yale
for supporting me in this work
and i'm grateful to all of the
researchers and advocates
who've blazed the trail whose work on
health equity
and racial justice too often went
unbelieved
or overlooked across the generations
most of all i'm thankful to my family
to jesse and our three children for
their
unwavering support and humor
and to my mother and her mother
for modeling kindness generosity
and courageous leadership through
service
i have wanted to be a doctor since i was
six years old
and i'm a proud general internal
medicine physician today
but as i grew up i came to understand
that there were deeper dimensions to
health beyond what i saw in the human
biology textbooks
that i borrowed from my mother's
bookshelf
i grew up on saint thomas in the u.s
virgin islands a place where people too
often
die too young from preventable
conditions
my own father had his first stroke in
his 40s
and was left paralyzed i learned there
was a term for what we were
an underserved community marginalized
by place and by race
in my medical training i saw countless
patients
whose conditions were shaped by factors
having nothing to do with science
and everything to do with broader social
inequity
and now the kovid 19 crisis has laid
those inequities
there it is not a coincidence
and it is not a matter of genetics that
more than 70
of african americans and more than 60
of latinx americans personally know
someone who has been hospitalized
or died from coven 19.
the same disparities ingrained in our
economy
our housing system our food system our
justice system
and so many other areas of our society
have conspired in this moment
to create a grief gap that we cannot
ignore
it is our societal obligation to ensure
equitable access
to testing treatments and vaccines
equitable support for those who are
hurting
and equitable pathways to opportunity as
we emerge from this crisis and rebuild
including for those most marginalized
communities
the undocumented the incarcerated the
homeless
i'm grateful for this chance to continue
this work
to earn trust and to find success
through genuine partnerships
with the people and communities who've
been hit the hardest
during and before the crisis
on this team you will be heard
you will be counted and you will be
valued
thank you
president-elect biden and vice
president-elect harris
thank you so much for asking me to be
part of this covet response team
i hope that you don't mind that our
reason that i am sending this video
is because a close friend and colleague
at the nih
dr harvey alter is receiving the nobel
prize in medicine
at the same time and we wanted to attend
the ceremony at the nih
to show our support such an achievement
is a reminder of the incredible public
servants
we have at the nih and of america's
place
as a pioneer in science and medicine
i believe as you do that in the fight
against this pandemic
we must lead with science and that a key
piece
of our ongoing work is communicating
consistently
with the american people whether it's
maintaining
social distancing and not congregating
indoors
or the 100-day challenge you described
on masking
or to get as many people vaccinated as
possible
these actions are bold but they are
doable
and essential to help the public avoid
unnecessary risks
to help us save lives reopen schools and
businesses
and to eventually beat the pandemic
i look forward to advising you on these
most urgent priorities
and to work with this team of
world-class experts
whom i have known for many years and
deeply respect
i have been through many public health
crises before
but this is the toughest one we have
ever faced as a nation
the road ahead will not be easy
we have got a lot of hard and demanding
work to do
in the next year but as we have done
during previous crises
i also know we can get through this
pandemic together
as a nation thank you for giving me the
opportunity
to be part of this effort
[Music]
president-elect biden and vice
president-elect harris
i'm honored by your trust in me and
humbled
by the task at hand and i am hopeful
because of your leadership as it is for
both of you
everything starts with family for me and
i am forever grateful for the love
and support of my wife our children
and our parents mr president-elect
we've known each other for a long time
and our relationship
has been forged under immense pressure
the severity of the great recession
the challenge of implementing the
affordable care act
and the daily decisions a white house
makes that affect the lives of millions
of americans
you and president obama knew how to
build a team
with the right diversity of backgrounds
and views
a team to make progress on difficult
situations
and capture enormous opportunities
that's what i've tried to do throughout
my career
i'm not a doctor or public health expert
in fact we've got the best ones in the
world
on this team but i do know management
and execution and the key part of the
role you've asked me to take on
is the last part coordinator
it's about empowering experts developing
a culture of teamwork and maintaining a
focus
on strategy and execution
it's knowing that leadership requires
expertise
transparency and prioritization
it also requires trust truth
and integrity to the american people
that's what this team will provide
we will utilize the full capacity of the
federal government
to get this pandemic under control
to harness and examine the data to
expand testing
to deliver equipment and ppe
to those on the front lines to provide
resources for schools
and businesses to operate safely
to address the racial disparities and
inequities
of this pandemic to rejoin the global
fight against covet 19
because no one is safe until everyone is
safe
and with our collective expertise we
will oversee the rollout of the vaccine
which is the president-elect said will
be one of the greatest operational
challenges
our country has ever faced
and we also will pull the country
together
across governments at the federal state
and local levels
and across the private sector
and as we begin this work mr mr
president-elect
i remember what you told me when we were
implementing the affordable care act
your message was i know this
is no small task i know
you and the team are feeling tremendous
pressure to succeed
and we want and need the team to pull
this off
you then said i know you and the team
can do this
but i need to promise you promise me one
thing
that you will always always
give it to us straight because we have
to understand the challenge
we're facing because most of all
we're in this together and together
we can do this president-elect biden
vice president-elect harris and the
american people
this team will always give it to you
straight
the work ahead will not be easy
but we know what needs to be done and we
will get it done
together thank you
well congratulations mr president-elect
um on nominating and appointing a most
outstanding team to get this pandemic
under control
and thank you to these accomplished
physicians
and experts and public servants for
answering the call
to serve the american people in this
critical hour of need
over thanksgiving the president-elect
and i called healthcare workers
who are on the front lines of this
pandemic
just to thank them we wanted to express
our gratitude
and our nation's gratitude for
everything they have been doing
for every sacrifice they have made
that day i spoke with two registered
nurses
maureen in pennsylvania and talisa
in illinois they shared stories that
we've all heard
we've all heard the stories about
grandmothers and grandfathers
loved ones and friends spending their
last
moments alone we've all heard about
nurses and physicians
who are physically and mentally
exhausted
trying to keep up with ever increasing
caseloads
those on the front line who say to each
other
it's not a matter of when but it's a
matter not of when
but when when they will get the virus so
it is a matter of when and not if they
get the virus this is what they're
saying to each other every day
we've all heard about health care
workers without the supplies and
equipment they need
to care for patients and save lives
so today we have a message for talisa
maureen and all americans
help is on the way and it is long
overdue
the scale of this pandemic is
heartbreaking
as you know and have heard almost 15
million cases
more than 2 800 deaths in a single day
and then there is the economic
devastation
the lost jobs the small businesses
shuttered
not to mention what's happening to our
schools the parents and teachers who are
being stretched
to their limits and the toll it's taking
on the mental health
and well-being of our children who risk
each day falling behind opening our
schools and economy
safely and responsibly getting this
virus under control
all of it starts with listening to
experts and leaders
like these americans who reflect
the very best of our nation they are top
physicians
public health experts and public
servants and they are the team
that the american people need and
deserve
to make sure testing and treatment are
free for everyone
to make sure vaccines are safe free
and equitably distributed to make sure
we
are better prepared for future pandemics
and other
health threats and to make sure quality
affordable health care
is available to all
from an early age i saw the life-saving
work that our health care professionals
provide
especially for the most vulnerable among
us
you see my mother was a breast cancer
researcher and my sister and i
spent many hours roaming the hallways of
the hospital where she worked
i'm sure your kids have too and it's why
i
actually later co-founded an auxiliary
group to help patients at the county
hospital in oakland california
more than 20 years ago it's why we need
to protect and expand
the affordable care act and it's why we
have to listen
to front line health care workers like
maureen and talisa
in fact during our conversation talisa
said
we wouldn't send our soldiers to battle
without the gear they need
and we shouldn't then send our doctors
and our nurses
to fight this pandemic without the gear
they need
and of course she's right and
president-elect biden and i
along with this world-class team will
make sure we are doing
everything we can to save lives and
contain this pandemic
once and for all getting this virus
under control is one of the defining
challenges of our time
and we will do what the american people
have always done in the face
of a great challenge we will
stand together and we
will defeat it thank you
thank you president
okay
no i was getting back there